hey this is presh talwalker
this is said to be one of the hardest
sat questions ever
what is the greatest possible area of a
triangle with one side of length seven
and another side of length 10.
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
I will present two ways to solve the
problem
the first method uses trigonometry
the area of a triangle can be expressed
as a b over 2 multiplied by the sine of
theta
interestingly this was first known to
the Indian mathematician Arya butt
in this case we have a and b are equal
to 7 and 10. so the area only depends on
the sine of theta where Theta is the
angle between these two sides
we know the maximum possible value of
sine Theta is one and that occurs when
Theta is equal to 90 degrees
substituting in the largest possible
area
is one-half multiplied by seven
multiplied by ten and that's one half of
70 which is equal to 35. and that's one
way to solve the problem
another method is a visual method using
geometry
let's have one length of 10 and leave
the other length of seven
now we can consider all possible
triangles by changing this length of
seven
this length of 7 will span a semi-circle
and we can see the different heights of
all possible triangles
the largest height will happen when the
length of 7 is perpendicular to the
length of 10 and we form a right
triangle
so once again we can see the greatest
possible area is equal to one-half
multiplied by seven multiplied by ten
and that's equal to 35 and that's the
answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time